nachdem wir bei der türkischen Oma essen
durften ist heute ein italienische Nonna
dran ich bin ganz ehrlich als würde
dieses Format überlegt habe wollte ich
bei meiner Mama Essen deshalb freue ich
mich auf den Tag es ist nicht
irgendeiner Nummer sondern die Oma von
Erics Freundin da gehen wir jetzt hin
und lassen uns komplett durch füttern
los geht's da sind wir mitten in Italien
ich sag dir wirklich seitdem ich den
Erik kenne jeden Sonntag wir gehen zu
Norah ich sehe hier schon Zucchini ja
hier vorne
panieren okay
ich freue mich so sehr hier zu sein
überanstränge kocht immer so viel was
ich gehört habe aber ich freue mich dass
wir uns kennenlernen ja der erik hat
immer erzählt immer gesagt die Nonne hat
gekocht hat mir Fotos geschickt und ich
war immer so neidisch und heute darf ich
endlich auch probieren
sehr gut dann schauen wir mal wie es
weitergeht also gar keinen Stress heute
auch wenn man mit einer Kamera dabei
sind alles wie immer
[Musik]
der Moment auf den ich gewartet habe es
gibt was zu essen vielen Dank Nora ich
finde auch alleine so mit der Tischdecke
und so das ist alles schon so original
ja wir sehen Erbsen ein Tomatensoße mit
Hackfleisch Penne und ich finde wirklich
das sieht aus wie ein Sizilien ohne dass
ich jemals war also vielen lieben Dank
fürs Kochen vielen Dank dass ich da sein
darf wie nennen wir dieses Gerät
so einfach nur mit zu einem einfaches ja
dann probieren wir mal so klischeehaft
Deutsch denkt würde man denken okay
Erbsen so in Tomatensoße aber das gibt's
wirklich ganz viel in Italien ich glaube
spätestens wenn wir nebeneinander sitzen
ist das der beweisen
sehr lecker auf die Nudeln haben schön
ein bisschen schöner al dente so wie es
sein muss hat so einen besonderen
Geschmack das wie die Tomaten sind das
gehackte Tomaten passierte Tomaten was
sagt denn passierte Tomaten dann schön
fein und ich finde es auch so schlau so
effizient ne also wir haben eine
unheimliche Vielfalt von Gericht mehr
Zucchini Aubergine Pasta alles was das
Herz begehrt nur noch wir haben schon
sehr viel gesehen einige deiner Tricks
konnten wir schon kennenlernen aber wie
hast du diese Soße gemacht
ein bisschen geschmerzen habe ich äh der
letzte und dann habe ich schon
eingebracht mit meinst du Schweine
gehabt ist
und dann habe ich eine App das Torso bis
eingebracht und habe ich äh na ja das
kostet 2 Stunden langsam kochen und dann
sah zum Pfeffer und klein bisschen zu
klein für die Tomaten
sehr sehr lecker man merkt aber auch
dass es lange gekocht hat trotzdem ist
es noch schön flüssig ja ist noch ein
bisschen Wasser dann auch noch dabei
wahrscheinlich oder wenn es zu wenig
wird kommt Wasser raus man merkt
wirklich direkt das ist ein Klassiker
aber einer den man hierzulande auf jeden
Fall nicht so gut kennt leider weil es
wirklich sehr gut die allererste
Gelegenheit den Teller nachzufüllen
wurde gerade auf jeden Fall auch schon
mit Freude genutzt voneinander
schmeckt echt gut oh nein
die parmigianer
Parmigiana aber interessant in eurem
Fall ohne Parmigiano oder eigentlich
wahrscheinlich im Namen steckt ja
Parmigiano also Parmesan wahrscheinlich
ist diese Kruste von den Auberginen
normalerweise Parmesan ich habe einen
Schüleraustausch nach Italien gemacht
ich konnte nie glauben dass wie es im
Schulbuch steht wirklich die Familien
mit mehreren Gängen jeden Tag essen aber
das stimmt also als ich da war in
Trieste Norditalien wir haben jeden
Abend drei Gänge gegessen immer antip
Pasta und dann Hauptgericht und meistens
sogar noch eine Süßigkeit hinterher und
gerade nimmt das alles den gleichen
glaube es wird aufgedeckt aufgedeckt
aufgedeckt und man kommt gar nicht aus
dem Grinsen raus jetzt ist aufgetischt
wir haben so viele verschiedene Gerichte
wir haben eine Installateur wir haben
per Patte mit Zucker und Kartoffel dann
haben wir Parmigiana ohne Parmesan
Zucchini und galoppine wenn wir mal
durchziehen 1 2 3 4 5 Sachen 1 zweites
also wir hatten schon die Pasta und du
kochst das mit 84 was probiere ich als
erstes so ein bisschen wie an so einem
Festessen man muss erstmal gucken
dann nehme ich noch ein bisschen Soße
und rüber
genug sein die ist schön eingedickt
einfach nur
Orangensaft Zitrone und Mehl oder ein
bisschen Butter
machen
Butter weiß man braucht gar kein Wasser
dafür ich probiere mal
so viele von euch die diesen Geschmack
nicht kennen dieses unauffällige vom
Hähnchen aber dazu dann die zitronente
muss man gegessen haben um zu verstehen
sehr lecker habe ich schon ein zwei mal
probieren dürfen ich glaube der Erik
hatte mir was mitgebracht von Sonntag ja
und dann habe ich direkt am nächsten Tag
auch zu Hause selbst gekocht das ist so
eine gute Kombination auch geiles
Fitness food oder weil so die Soße
besteht aus ein bisschen Olivenöl und
Mehl und der Rest ist so Orangensaft und
Zitronensaft die Soße ist auch so
schnell gemacht
[Musik]
ich habe gerade mal durchgezählt ich
glaube keines der einzelnen Gerichte hat
mehr als 5 Zutaten das ist einfache
Küche die italienische oder
andere Küche und das einfach das ist
einfach aber auch einfach lecker die
galoppine sind so gut und schmecken so
anders als alles was man kennt und das
mit fünf Zutaten was ist eigentlich dein
Lieblingsessen
als nächstes möchte ich die probieren
weil der Eric schwärmt immer davon diese
Frikadelle quasi ja es ist sehr gut ja
die ist schön weich merkt man schon wenn
man so mit dem Messer angeht
wahrscheinlich weil die das so ein
bisschen aufsaugt
man denkt gar nicht dass es soweit
hinbekommen
ja sehr gut in der Soße gekocht
butterweichen so ein bisschen
Tomatengeschmack ein bisschen vom Zucker
aber trotzdem so ganz weich
was ist in den Frikadellen denn alles
genau drinne
Eier eingeweichtes Brötchen
ja
ein bisschen gelernt heute auf jeden
Fall vielleicht kann ich Dir bald die
Weichen machen aber dann anbraten er
eher mit heißer Pfanne oder langsamer
und muss ein bisschen mehr Öl sonst wenn
welche dann kommen wir nicht so richtig
kochen so gemacht habe ich hier auch ein
bisschen Salat geben
würde ich jetzt vom Auge sagen das ist
kein klassisch italienischer das ist
einfach ein normaler spezialsalat oder
ist das ein typisches italienischer
Salat auch
ja ja okay tut auf jeden Fall auch gut
so was Frisches zwischendrin zu haben so
so ein bisschen zum Erfrischen
Donnerstag wie eine Oma kocht ne schönen
durchgebraten schön viel Öl über allem
das muss gut schmecken so viele von den
Sachen obwohl ich so gern die
italienische Küche macht habe ich noch
gar nicht gegessen habe
die Zucchini das ist fast schon ein
bisschen süß und ne durch die Kinder
sehr lecker
langsam aber sicher werde ich ein
bisschen satt aber nicht ohne alles
probiert zu haben ich nehme ein bisschen
von der Frittata ein bisschen gibt sich
einmal nicht
ich habe das ja gerade eben schon so
probiert deshalb bin ich gespannt ob das
jetzt noch besser schmeckt es war
wirklich schon sehr gut und ich nehme
hier ein bisschen von der hamidana ich
probiere auch direkt kein Fleisch kann
nichts drin oder so
[Musik]
hast du schon mal gegessen noch nicht ne
war wirklich sehr lecker die Aubergine
die hat aber so ein Geschmack so das
Gefühl im Mund ist wie von der Lasagne
mit Fleisch was wirklich sehr sehr
lecker auch wieder hier so diese Frische
von der Tomate alles super simpel so man
schmeckt auch die einfache Tomatensoße
aber es ist trotzdem sehr sehr gut ja
und alles auf der Basis dieser einen
Soße halten ja
dann jetzt noch ein bisschen von der
Frittata patata Frittata dein Vater das
letzte was ich heute esse ich bin jetzt
aber auch wirklich Sattler deshalb danke
schön dass du meinen Bauch gefüllt hast
ich glaube das wird lecker
schmeckt ganz anders als einfach nur
gebraten es hat trotzdem noch so diese
Cremigkeit das schmeckt wirklich
noch ein bisschen flüssig dazu diese
Tomatensoße so einfach kann gutes Essen
sein einfach ist es nicht mehr wenn man
sechs Gerichte auf einmal macht danke
für den Anfang wirklich danke dass wir
das Video drehen durften schön dass ich
Gast sein dürfte das ist mir geworden
für 84 danke fürs zusehen wir sehen uns
beim nächsten Mal wieder macht's gut und
bis dahin ciao
[Gelächter]